the 2020 race for the white house
is more unpredictable than ever a
campaign already upended
by the coronavirus pandemic dozens of
ballots were thrown into a dumpster
new concern that election day could
stretch well beyond november 3rd
the economist is analyzing the latest
data to cut through the noise and
predict
the results you submitted your questions
to eliot morris
our data journalist and election guru
here are his answers
[Music]
in 2016 hillary clinton was the favorite
by a large margin
why should we trust the data this time
that is the million dollar question
right uh so polls this time
should be better but that's no guarantee
and there are a few reasons
why that's the case the first is the
technical methodological explanation
and that is that the reason that some
polls were wrong especially in the
midwest
in states like michigan and wisconsin uh
was because they
they missed uh the crucial block of
non-college-wide voters in the
electorate that support
donald trump by a few percentage points
and the reason that's the case is
because those voters are less likely to
take
public opinion polls than voters with a
college degree who are more likely to
support
democrats this year it seems like most
pollsters are making those adjustments
correctly and that the polls should not
underestimate support for trump in the
same way this year
that they did last time around there's
also
another consideration that might make
polls better and that's that there
are fewer undecided voters in the
electorate this time around
so in 2016 there was upwards of 15
percent
of voters who said they were unlikely to
vote or they didn't know who
they were going to vote for or they were
going to vote for a third-party
candidate
and this year that number in total is
really closer to five percent
and that makes us more confident that
joe biden's lead in the polls is robust
and likely to last
how many unknowns do you suspect could
make election predictions inaccurate
there are a few things that could make
our predictions wrong and the first
thing is obviously having to do with the
polls
if they're talking to the wrong people
or there's a late shift
that happens after the last polls are
done sampling
sampling voters then they could go awry
but this year there are also some
particular problems
with the pandemic so pollsters rely on
asking people
if they'll actually turn out to vote and
if
one party is more likely to overestimate
their tendency to actually vote
then the polls would overestimate their
support so you can imagine a pandemic
in a year where donald trump is telling
most of his voters to vote in
person that republicans could be more
exposed to
uh telling pollsters that they're more
likely to vote than they really are
and that could make uh polls biased
against them now that's just one story
that's just conjecture
but it's one potential source of error
what does voter turnout look like in the
swing states
so voter turnout looks to be up pretty
much everywhere that includes in swing
states
and in other states in some states early
voting already accounts for 20
or more of total turnout in 2016
which is quite astonishing and that has
downstream electoral consequences as
well so
we know from past research at the
economist that when turnout
is higher that tends to benefit
democrats and that's mainly in diverse
states so
the sun built states that look
competitive this year like arizona
texas georgia and north carolina and to
some extent florida which is
always competitive really joe biden has
an upside
and that more voters are turning out
this time than would have in 2016.
do you incorporate early voting into
your forecasting model
our model doesn't use early voting data
and most
forecasting models don't and there are a
few reasons
why the first is that it's hard to get
data from each state
on who exactly is casting early ballots
so some states might tell you that there
are democrats and republicans voting and
this is how many ballots are coming from
them
but most states don't even if a state
does tell you that there are democrats
or republicans voting
there's a difference between when
somebody registers as a democrat or
republican with the government
and they also by the way have the
ability to register with no party
in some states and how they actually
vote a recent poll in pennsylvania
for example found uh that about
70 of registered republicans were
actually voting for donald trump
uh which leaves about 30 percent who
aren't so it's just hard to guess
at which partisans are going to vote for
who the real
forecasting information comes from
the state of the economy and the
president's approval rating
so we know historically when a president
is
has has a low popularity or when the
economy is
shrinking that they tend to do poorly in
the election
does your model consider high rejection
rates of ballots
there are a few ways that high rejection
rates of ballots
could influence our predictions uh
now historically uh there is some
disconnect
uh between who people say they're going
to vote for and the actual
count of ballots in a state that can
explain some
pollster error of course and rejection
rates
is one of them so we know in most states
that
uh younger and african-american voters
have their ballots rejected at higher
rates
and historically that that the error
caused by this dynamic is captured
in our election model but if there is a
spike
this year in how likely rejections are
for younger or african-american or
lower-income voters
that could cause further error in the
model
and we know from from separate modeling
that that could
very well be true this year that joe
biden
could face an extra one or two
percentage point drop
in severe states for rejection rates uh
just based
on on slow delivery on young people
not having their signatures match up
with the state file and the sort of
numerous other reasons for rejections
can in ballots be discarded as easily as
some fear
[Music]
so the the sort of conspiracy theories
about
people just discarding ballots or
putting them in the trash
are quite overblown those are really
rare occasions that
don't impact a lot of votes but there
are
real concerns about the ways that the
laws around absentee ballots are
structured
in america they can have
disproportionate effects like we've
talked about for
younger and non-white americans
who move around a lot so they don't have
an address for election workers to
verify
or who don't have driver's licenses so
they don't have signatures
already in the state's voter system that
that election workers use to verify
absentee ballots
uh or in lower income areas we know the
postal service
uh works more slowly than it does in
other areas of the country for whatever
reason
uh which could make those ballots late
so so i'm less worried about people
intentionally discarding ballots
and reformers are more worried about the
real structural problems with the system
how long can we expect to wait for the
results
so we should have a really good idea of
what's going to happen
by around 9 or 10 p.m eastern time and
that's because that's when florida
should have about 90 or 95 of its
ballots casted at least
if patterns from 2016 uh hold true
and the reason that florida is so
important
is because it tells us a lot about how
other states are going to vote
so the way our election model works is
by
arranging states from left to right
based off of their projected vote
share essentially and we know if florida
is going blue then most of the states
to the left of florida like the
midwestern states or
maybe even arizona this year are also
likely to vote for joe biden so
essentially if he wins florida and we
should know pretty early if he does
then he's on track to win the election
our model would give him close to
a 95 chance you know a pretty sure thing
uh barring unforeseen consequences at
that point we would be able to predict
the result
could one candidate appear to be winning
on election night
but lose once all ballots have been
counted
there's been a lot of concern this year
about this so-called red mirage or blue
wave
effect where absentee ballots which can
sometimes take a while to count
are more democratic leaning than other
ballots so the thinking goes this year
that because there are going to be so
many absentee ballots and because we're
in a pandemic
and we might have fewer poll workers
that they'll take longer to count
and that's probably true however
the the chance for the electoral college
to flip over time but after
a lot of ballots are counted is
relatively low
the economist looked at this earlier
this year and found that
once 80 percent or so of both absentee
and election day ballots are counted
then the election would line up with the
result
how likely are americans to not accept
the election result
and what would be the impact of this
yeah that's a really important question
this year when we have
politicians questioning the results
already
it's pretty likely that citizens would
do the same
and we have polls that show from yougov
and from a partnership between ucla and
this
research organization called the
democracy fund that people are pretty
likely to endorse
violence or unrest if their side loses
especially in the case where they view
that loss
as undemocratic so republicans in the
case
of widespread illegal voting which by
the way
we haven't ever seen evidence before of
our likelier to endorse violence against
opponents or again widespread unrest
and democrats are likely to do the same
if there's a mismatch between the
electoral college and the popular vote
like there was last time around
but when we talk about tolerance for
violence that's also a lot different
than actually going out and you know
hurting your opponents i think this is
less
of a concern if either candidate wins by
a large amount
where you know if joe biden has the
eight or nine point margin that our
forecast
is uh projecting today then it's harder
to call the election and the dow
hi i'm elliot morris a member of the
economists
data team with election day less than
four weeks away
you can join my colleagues from our u.s
team for a live digital event we're
hosting
especially for economist readers and
viewers
we'll be discussing the economic impact
of the election
and answering any questions you may have
about the remainder
of the campaign this event is completely
free
to register for it just click on the
link thanks for watching